44 it's Monday morning the fashion show
mall has a new experience it'll take you
back in time
Huey Lewis reference okay it's a selfie
studio and
decades so Candace Charles joining us
live this morning at the Fashion Show
Mall you said 60s Candace that was your
favorite
you hit it on the nose Heather I love
the 60s I have a little bit of a hippie
heart good morning to you guys good
morning folks but this time John I have
not gone back to the past but to the
Future yes I look a little bit like the
Matrix I'm getting very much Matrix
Vibes but this is just one of the eight
booths you can come on down here and
check out I have Jane share here with me
from the fashion show mall thank you so
much for joining us this morning tell us
a little bit more about these other ones
absolutely so you can start with the 50s
and get as you said go all the way to
the future visit the now and they all
just really encapsulate some of the most
nostalgic moments from all of these
different decades yeah this is really
giving me all of the text messages we
get all the hashtags of course you gotta
take a look at yourself before you get
your selfie done and this was created by
a group out of Atlanta right tell us a
little bit about the design team as we
walk over to the 2000s of course so
they're it's a designed firm called the
NGK based out of Atlanta Atlanta was
actually the first stop on the tour and
we are the second very cool and now I'm
feeling so fetched I saw that they have
mashed over here all the old school like
flip phones definitely making me feel
just a little bit old Jamie that's
totally fine and this weekend you have
something special for the moms as well
right we do so on Mother's Day from 11
to 3 we're actually going to have a
professional photographer here so you
can come to Fashion Show and shop and
eat and stop by selfie Studio decades
tour and get some photos taken with your
mom but then you can find the great
outfits to go with it and all the
different options for it as well thank
you so much Jane so much fun we
appreciate you guys and now I have been
transported to 90s for those of you that
are really young these are called VHS
tapes I know amazing you guys can find
out more details about this wonderful
art installation on our website
newsnow.com and of course this is all
open all the way to the end of the month
and guys it's completely free yes free
99. for now live from the Great Hall in
the fashion show mall in Candace Charles
Aiden is now I love the Be Kind Rewind
who could forget that it's burned into
our memory by the way spoiler I actually
almost watched a VHS version of
Desperado over the weekend I'm just more
impressed that you have a vhl player no
it didn't work it didn't work
hi Candace